der Norden Deutschlands produziert
günstige Windenergie für das ganze Land
und Zeit dafür mächtig drauf wie hier in
Schleswig-Holstein
ich würde das mal auf Strafgeld
bezeichnen je mehr Windräder desto höher
die Kosten das Problem der Transport von
Strom aus Erneuerbaren hakt die Folge es
entstehen Lücken die mit teuren fossilen
Alternativen gestopft werden müssen und
beides zusammen kostet uns jedes Jahr
eine Milliarde Euro für nichts und
wieder nichts ein meine
volkswirtschaftliche Katastrophe
Hartmut marscheider ist großer Fan von
erneuerbaren Energien die vielen
Windräder in seinem Heimatort
Friedrichskoog sind gar nicht mehr
wegzudenken das ist möglich man muss es
nur wollen und die Bayern wenn wir auf
die Bayern schimpfen wollen die wollten
es einfach nicht sie wollten angeblich
ihre Landschaft nicht verstanden aber
haben wir unsere Landschaft wir haben
sie verändert aber nicht verstanden
stellvertretenden Bürgermeister stört er
zahlt hier die Energiewende für die
süddeutschen mit was wir hier nicht so
gewusst haben hat uns auch ja keinen
erzählt dass es nur in Norddeutschland
so ist oder Windstrom produziert wird
das all die anderen die auch unseren
Strom verbrauchen die es nicht auf der
Rechnung finden und das ist eine
Ungerechtigkeit die an sich nicht da
sein darf es geht um Netzentgelte die
Zahl zwar jeder Stromkunde aber nirgend
sie so hoch wie im windrad-land
Schleswig-Holstein jedes neue Windrad
muss an das Stromnetz angeschlossen
werden dafür braucht es Leitungen das
kostet aber nicht die Betreiber sondern
die Verbraucher die Folge dort wo
besonders viele Windräder gebaut werden
Zahlen die Verbraucher besonders hohe
Netzentgelte und das schon seit Jahren
ich würde in der Entschädigung der
letzten 10-15 Jahre fordern ja aber ich
glaube da bin ich nicht alleine aber da
kämpft man gegen Windmühlen sagt man
hier so
dazu kommt
im Vergleich
vierköpfige Familie mit einem
Jahresverbrauch von 4000 Kilowattstunden
zahlt in Schleswig-Holstein 480 € in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern 449 € in Bayern
sind es lediglich 323 € und in
Baden-Württemberg sogar nur 321 €.
Wind ist ein wichtiger Träger in der
Energiewende woran ist Deutschland aber
mangelt an der passenden Infrastruktur
der Experte appelliert
die Infrastruktur muss der Erzeugung
sinnvoll folgen und nicht umgekehrt wir
können nicht das Pferd von hinten auf
zornen und jetztige Infrastruktur
entsprechend den Erneuerbaren aufdrücken
sondern wir müssen die Chancen der
Erneuerbaren nutzen um ein
kostengünstiges System zu bekommen und
die Infrastruktur daraufhin anpassen
günst wünschen sich auch die Rudolfs das
Ehepaar betreibt eine Ferienanlage
direkt an der Nordseeküste die hohen
Netzentgelte belasten das
Kleinunternehmen darunter leiden auch
die Gäste als Wettbewerbsnachteil würde
ich das
insofern bezeichnen dass wir natürlich
mit unseren hohen Stromkosten auch
höhere Preise
ausschreiben müssen
die uns im Wettbewerb natürlich auch
benachteiligen gegenüber unseren
südlichen Kollegen
gleichzeitig Gefährte der träge Netz
Ausbau aber auch das Geschäft im so der
Fachmann
letztendlich ist es aber sehr nachteilig
für den Süden Deutschlands wenn wir die
Energiewende bei uns so verschlafen weil
einfach viel Energie intensive
Produktion oder auch Industriebetriebe
sich definitiv überlegen und wo kann ich
den klimaneutral produzieren seine
Warnung Süddeutschland werde als
Industriestandort unattraktiver
Unternehmen wandern ab setzen
zunehmend und könnten sich eher in
Richtung Norden ansiedeln dort im Norden
stehen Windkraftanlagen immer wieder
still trotz windigem Wetter
ist eine Schande eine Schande an sich
dass wir hier oben so viel Strom
produzieren und den mehr oder weniger
wegschmeißen
nach ihren günstigeren Strom als fossile
Energieträger das drückt den Preis auf
dem Strommarkt der gilt für ganz
Deutschland
das heißt ich kann im Bayern Strom aus
Schleswig-Holstein einkaufen dann wird
dieses Handelsergebnis dem Netzbetreiber
übergeben und der sagt dann aber ein
Moment mal ich habe gar nicht die
Leitung dass ich diesen Handel erfüllen
kann und der Strom tatsächlich vom
Norden in den Süden kommt die Folge die
Windräder werden abgeregelt oder
ausgeschaltet um den im Süden bereits
eingekauften aber nicht lieferbaren
Strom ersetzen zu können werden dort
Reservekraftwerke angeworfen das sind
meist teure Gas und Kohlekraftwerke die
den Preis wieder nach oben treiben und
zwar über die netzegelte dazu kommt der
nicht genutzte Strom wird trotzdem
vergütet als Entschädigung für die
Betreiber auch das läuft über die
Netzentgelte Verbraucher zahlen also
sowohl den nicht genutzten Strom als
auch einen höheren Preis für den
stattdessen teurer bereitgestellten
Ersatz-
zusammen kostet uns jedes Jahr eine
Milliarde Euro für nichts und wieder
nichts ein meine volkswirtschaftliche
Katastrophe es ist eine kurzfristige
Lösungsmöglichkeit
um den Ausbau von erneuerbarer Energie
nicht zu behindern aber er ist natürlich
langfristig nicht tragbar und sinnvoll
und muss durch Leitungsbau beseitigt
werden
Netzausbau so lautet die Devise ein
wichtiger Schritt südlink eine 700 km
lange Stromtrasse die grünen Strom von
der Nordsee in den Süden der Republik
transportieren soll ihr Ausbau
verzögerte sich jahrelang Fertigstellung
soll jetzt 2028 sein wenn alles gut
läuft aber auch wenn der Transport dann
besser klappt der Ausbau von Windenergie
würde immer noch primär im Norden
bezahlt
Fan von diesem Windparks und von diesem
Wind Rädern weil das ist Energie die wir
gut brauchen und und haben müssen als
Alternative zu dem was wir bisher haben
da bin ich auch gerne bereit meinen
Beitrag zu leisten aber der muss auch
gerecht verteilt sein da muss der
Gesetzgeber eingreifen und sagen so
Freunde jetzt haben wir die Leitung
jetzt transportieren wir den Strom von
Nord nach Süd und das kann nur zu einem
Preis
funktionieren also das heißt der Süden
zahlt genauso viel wie der Norden auch
der Experte sagt bei der Energiewende
muss jeder ran
die Technologien sind alle da die wir
brauchen wir müssen es nur politisch
umsetzen mit der entsprechenden
Priorität und alle auch gemeinschaftlich
denken und nicht nur aus Egoismus sagen
ja wir torpedieren jetzt wie es unsere
Landesregierung gemacht hat in Bayern
einfach die
die Bundespolitik keine Tassen ausbauen
bzw kein Wind keine Speicher und dann
stehen wir da wo wir heute stehen sein
Appell alle sollten die Vorteile von
Windenergie nutzen können und alle
sollten die Kosten für ihre Förderung
tragen müssen das zu regeln bleibt
Aufgabe der Politik